aquí tenemos un círculo y supongamos que
conocemos su circunferencia que es de 6
unidades
cualesquiera que sean veamos si podemos
encontrar dado que la circunferencia es
6 pi de estas unidades a que será igual
el área pausa en el vídeo y traten de
encontrarlo por su cuenta
primero traten de ver si pueden
encontrar el área para este círculo y
después traten de ver si pueden
encontrar una forma general para que
dada una circunferencia podamos
encontrar el área y viceversa resolvamos
esto juntos aquí la clave es darnos
cuenta de que con la circunferencia
podemos encontrar el radio y con el
radio podemos encontrar el área sabemos
que la circunferencia que es 6 pi es
igual a 2 por pi por radio así que a que
será igual el radio el radio que es esta
distancia vamos a dividir ambos lados de
esta igualdad entre dos pi
lo hacemos para despejar ere y nos queda
una erre del lado derecho y 3 del lado
izquierdo ya que pide entre pies 1 y 6
entre 2 estrés por lo que tenemos que
nuestro radio es de 3 unidades y después
usamos la fórmula del área que es igual
a pi por radio al cuadrado y así podemos
encontrar el área esto es igual a ti por
3 al cuadrado lo que es igual a 9 pi
así que para este ejemplo en particular
cuando la circunferencia mide 6 unidades
el área va a ser igual a 9 unidades
cuadradas unidades cuadradas ya que
estamos elevando al cuadrado el radio y
el radio está en unidades así que si lo
elevamos al cuadrado tendremos unidades
al cuadrado ahora veamos si podemos
encontrar una fórmula general
sabemos que la circunferencia es igual a
2 pi por radio y sabemos que el área es
igual a pi por radio al cuadrado podemos
encontrar una fórmula que sea una
relación directa entre la circunferencia
y el área y les doy una pista pueden
despejar r aquí y sustituirla en esta
otra fórmula o al revés pausa en el
vídeo y traten de hacerlo vamos a
hacerlo en esta fórmula despejemos r si
dividimos ambos lados entre dos pin que
es exactamente lo que hicimos aquí
arriba que es lo que nos queda pues del
lado derecho nos queda r que es igual
hace la circunferencia entre dos pi
y ahora para calcular el área recuerden
que el área es igual a ti por nuestro
radio al cuadrado y sabemos que el radio
es igual a la circunferencia entre dos
pi
así que lo sustituimos aquí recuerden
que queremos relacionar el área y la
circunferencia a que será igual esto
tenemos que el área es igual a pi por la
circunferencia al cuadrado entre dos pie
al cuadrado es cuatro pi al cuadrado si
multiplicamos esto tenemos un pie en el
numerador y pi cuadrada en el
denominador así que podemos quitar un
pie aquí y nos queda uno entre pi el
área es igual a la circunferencia al
cuadrado entre cuatro pi vamos a
escribirla por acá y no es una fórmula
que memorice mos muy seguido pero es
bastante bueno que podamos inferir la el
área es igual a la circunferencia al
cuadrado entre cuatro pi y podemos
hacerlo al revés si nos dan el área como
podemos encontrar la circunferencia
podemos poner las cantidades aquí o
despejarse
multiplicamos ambos lados por 4 pi si lo
hacemos nos queda 4 por área igualase al
cuadrado y para despejar la
circunferencia aplicamos la raíz
cuadrada en ambos lados de la igualdad
lo que nos da la raíz cuadrada de 4 y
por área igual a la circunferencia
podemos simplificar esto un poco más
quitando al 4 de este radical pero esto
está bastante bien ya que hemos
relacionado el área y la circunferencia